[Music]
white against tom flynn all right i feel
like going violet e4 let's go with
something more uh spicy and we got a
scandi okay so he's primo d5
now as you guys know against the scandi
okay knight f6 now this is a lesser
known continuation although it is a very
much viable uh
opening
and i've even recommended this to some
people now black is trying to take the
pawn on his own turns
and many of you may be surprised by this
move because it appears that white can
simply play c4
and keep the extra pawn
but if you know the theory of this line
you will know that c4 is not a panacea
because after c4 black has the move c6
and if you take on c6 then after knight
takes c6 black gets full control over
this d4 square and black gets tremendous
compensation for the pawn i will show
this after the game on the board but i
can't move the pieces so
the best approach here for white the
approach that was taught to me by my
coach many many years ago is to
basically say all right
you're going to lose this pawn we're
going to give it away
but
what we're going to make black do
is damage his position
and we're basically gonna force black
into a very awkward scheme of
development in return for taking the
pawn
so the first move that we're gonna play
here is bishop to b5 check
the point is not to keep the pawn
somehow it's to force a piece onto d7
this knight or if a bishop came to d7 is
very awkward right he's under a pin
knight bd7 is a legitimate move
and um
now we will go knight c3 and try to make
it as hard as possible for him to win
this pawn back
you should go a6 that's the move
all right now comes the moment when a
lot of people tend to go wrong because
the tempting move is bishop a4 but could
somebody tell me how black could meet
bishop a4 effectively why is bishop a4
like not that great here what we're
going to do is go back all the way to e2
so if we go bishop a4 then he goes b5 he
chases the bishop to c3 and then that
knight from d7 comes out to c5 like the
beast that it is and that bishop is
actually toast you're gonna have to give
it up for the knight we don't want that
yeah resign is right so instead we want
to preserve the bishop we drop it all
the way to e2 this is the line that i
was taught many many years ago
and now he's bringing the knight out to
b6 but notice how many moves he's
spending on taking back this pawn in in
the time that he's doing that we
complete our development as quickly as
possible now what does it mean to
complete your development here well we
can play knight f3 immediately but what
other moves should we play at least
after knight f3 or before knight f3
doesn't really matter but we should play
this move at some point that's d4 just
to control the center
and white is a slight advantage let's
trade the knight in order to avoid him
taking and ruining my pawn structure
takes with a queen that's a little
unusual
um i seem to i remember knight knight
takes d5 being the moon so here you know
knight f3 would be fine but since he's
taken to the queen we need to take a
second and consider whether we might be
uh we might not be better off with uh
some other system of development and
okay c4 would blunder the pawn so be
careful but i do
like an alternative to knight f3
in the form of bishop f3 bishop f3 gets
the bishop to the long diagonal
everybody should be on board with that
um
am i shouting am i loud um i i tend to
speak louder
louder let me make the mic a little bit
quieter i think i'm probably loud
um sorry if i am
okay so um
after bishop f3
uh you guys might be on board with the
bishop being on the long diagonal but
once the queen moves away
you might ask yourself well wait a
second um where are we going to put the
knight okay i'm going to make it louder
again yeah it takes away knight f3 so
how do we resolve that situation
how do we resolve that situation
yeah the knight simply comes out to e2
which is a perfectly viable workable
defen uh development square
and the purpose of putting the bishop
here not only is it on the long diagonal
it's going to make it hard for him to
get his bishop out because he's going to
have to take an extra tempo and somehow
protect this b7 pawn which he will lose
if he brings his bishop out
now a lot of people they they great they
have a fear of putting the knight on
these squares e2 and d2
which is unfounded honestly 92 is almost
always a legitimate development square
because the knight can go out to g3 it
can go to c3 it's not a permanent square
and there's nothing wrong with it
i i in my experience with students and
stuff people get this aversion to
bringing the knights out to anywhere
except c3 and f3 which you know if you
hit the 17 1800s you should try to be a
little bit more flexible about the way
you approach development
because you know
sometimes it's worth sacrificing a
marginal amount of activity to get one
of your other pieces to a good square
all right
so he's thinking about where to put his
queen
we're going to play 92 against almost
any any move i mean other than the check
on a5
yeah he's taking a while i mean i would
expect something like queen back to d8
black is fine here nothing terrible i
mean we're we're better we're slightly
better but
um
but nothing nothing extraordinary he's
played okay queen b5
so this is i think
i think this is interesting because he's
defending the pawn of this queen to in
order i think to accelerate the
development of the bishop uh perhaps to
f5 or g4
now i know that a lot of you are
probably tempted by a4 but remember the
golden rule do not make a move simply
because it creates a threat that threat
has to be meaningful in and of itself
um is a4 a meaningful threat
well if you think about it it is not
thank you holy pals because the queen
simply drops back to b6
and the queen is even safer on b6 than
it is on b5 let's keep the queen on b5
so that we'll later be able to attack it
with moves like c4 more meaningful
threats let's continue with 92.
bishop f5
okay now we should complete our
development of castles and so is he
this guy is good he's playing well
good active chess
yeah don't be reactive don't make moves
simply because they create threats
all right so think about what you want
to do if he castles
in particular think about where you want
to position this bishop if he castles
long which i'm anticipating
okay here's e6 never mind go z6 all
right
so
ah so now the situation has changed
now the situation has changed and just
because a move is bad in one position
does not mean it's bad in another
notice how the situation changed we no
longer have to worry about the safety of
our king
our bishop is now pressuring the pawn on
b7 as you guys know the queen is
generally the worst defender of any kind
of weakness because it's very easy to
chase away so again
now we need to consider a4 in a new
light
a4
he drops the queen to b6
we go a5 and chase the queen again
and if he goes back to b5 can you guys
find a third way to threaten the queen
and basically force it off of its
defense of b7
what am i talking about here a4 queen b6
a5 queen b5 knight slides into c3 chases
the queen and that queen has to abandon
the b7 pawn
now if you're smart after a5 you're
gonna go queen out back to a7 but that's
an incredibly passive square it's out of
the game that will be a win for us
and then we're going to continue
expanding on the queen side and in the
center with c4
yeah good job
boom
i'm hoping he goes back
because that'll be very instructive
knight c3 now if he goes to b4 that's
what i left out
what is white's move there this is very
very nice
and once you push your pawn to a5 this
should be something on the top of your
mind
rook a4 is correct beautiful rook a4
now the queen has to go back to d6 or e7
losing the crucial pawn on b7 his
position will start to collapse
immediately after we take it
i saw rook a4 i just didn't like yeah
exactly
actually played rocket four
i don't care i literally don't care
okay so bishop takes b7
and um
this is going to be another great
example of not playing reactively
because after rook b8 i am positive that
perhaps most of you are
would lean toward bringing the bishop
back to f3 which would be a completely
legitimate move
but there is a stronger move right you
should always on every moment you should
consider well is there something
stronger is there a way that i can
increase the initiative and the moment
you ask yourself this question the move
queen f3 comes to mind
if you look at that position for a
second you might notice that it does
hang c2 but that pawn on c2 is
completely unimportant what's more
important here is the advantage in
development that we have that's even
more important than the pawn on b7 which
we took
why is that pawn important because that
pawn was defending the c3 is the c6
square see do you guys see that after
queen f3 you are preparing at the same
time two moves bishop f4 developing with
tempo
and also bishop drops back to c6 with an
incredibly nasty check
um and this rook could become involved
if we play a later move d45 and then it
could get involved uh laterally with
rookie four
so
notice that i'm not really calculating
right now i'm not calculating specific
moves i'm just trying to generate ideas
which really really helps in like a
blitz game because it'll allow you to
accelerate the pace of your play queen
f3 i can play almost instantly
he's probably going to take
and
then we have a big menu of options
now
another
way to conceptualize the screen on d6
right
we are sort of threatening to play
bishop f4 and develop a tempo but we may
also choose to delay that move we may
choose to play bishop f4 at a more
opportune moment the opportunity to
attack your opponent's queen
is a trump card that you can play at
some moment and playing it too fast
can
while it's not terrible in and of itself
i don't know if i'm making sense right
now but there might be you might be
forfeiting an opera to a more juicy
opportunity to play bishop f4
and um this is exactly the case here i
think we have a amazing way to set up
bishop f4 oh actually no never mind
scratch everything i just said this was
a huge mistake
uh because the queen can no longer drop
the d8 now bishop f4 is extremely strong
can somebody explain to me how rook d8
changed the landscape of the situation
i i just didn't internalize that move
thank you ah poor grips hello
and thank you
yeah queen can't go back to d7 because
of the screw it's got to go to e7
and that is devastating
now bishop c6 first was not necessary uh
this is we can play bishop c6 after
queen e7
yeah now we give this now again we could
take on a6
notice something very important
queen c6 check may appear to be more
tempting but as the rule goes when you
have a task you can do it with multiple
pieces which piece should you put on
that square the piece of lowest value
because after queen c6 check he has the
additional opportunity of queen to d7
not that it saves him
but after bishop c6 he has to drop back
with a knight
look at his king look at his position
let's very patiently find the most
precise path to victory
now how am i thinking about this what
are the candidate moves
many things win you can take on c7
that's the simple approach but i don't
find that to be particularly satisfying
because he goes rook to c8 he attacks
our bishop we have to spend a tempo
the second thing that i see the second
thing that i see is the king and the
queen on the same file
that is incredibly dangerous that is an
incredibly dangerous situation how can
we exploit it well ideally we'd play
knight to d5 and then smothered made him
on c7 but after knight d5 he plays e
takes d5
and we cannot play rookie one because
that square is unprotected we would
blunder checkmate
but in such situations you can invert
the move order so you can begin with
rookie one and then either play pawn to
d5 as many of you are proposing ripping
open the position but even more
effective is the move knight to d5
because it creates the immediate threat
against the queen he probably has to
take it and give up the queen but that
loses otherwise we basically checkmate
him on c7
yep
we can play it anyway knight d5
threatening smothered me
which is more important and we trap his
queen too look at this position
complete domination
he has to take that's the best that he
can do but he's gonna be down the queen
there
we're gonna have to do some cleanup work
but it'll be very easy
yeah the lower piece value thing i tell
that to my students all the time and
it's not a common piece of advice
but if i may and i appreciate it mason
but
i'm going to pat myself on the back here
and say that i think it's
actually very very helpful
because
it's not intuitive people want to do
stuff with the highest value piece you
want to do stuff with the queen because
it sounds like
um because it sounds like queen is going
to be more reliable at accomplishing a
task but that's not how stuff works on
the ground sometimes it is
but there are other times when giving a
check with a queen
is less powerful because he can block
with his queen and he can't do that if
you give a check with the bishop so it
does make sense if you think about it
okay now what should we do here
how should we keep the foot on the gas
pedal
don't just meekly drop back to g3 you
have an opportunity to basically finish
the game bishop takes c7 exposing the
attack on the bishop and against the
rook
and this is over now he can play rook c8
and then we're just gonna vacuum up the
bishop and then the pawn
we're gonna have a gazillion extra pawns
and an extra queen
i had a smothered mate yesterday against
kolars
yeah so he correctly plays rook c8 now
there's some shenanigans we could do
but no need we'll just take
intake defending the bishop and creating
more pressure against the knight
he can actually castle he should he
should castle here after bishop takes d7
what would be the idea the idea would be
rook d8 winning back the bishop
it doesn't change anything though we
don't need to rush into winning this
position we could just bring the rook
into the game with rook c4
this position is resignable not because
of the queen but because of the
combination of being up a queen
for a rook and a piece which is
legitimate compensation
oh and i missed a better move i missed a
beautiful move here
this will be a great challenge for you
guys queen takes d5 was inaccurate it's
still completely winning obviously
but i had a beautiful tactical resource
i didn't apply my queen e5 yeah forking
the rooks
and good job by my opponent to um let's
bring the rook into the game uh
finding the most resilient continuations
so six seven pawns to four puns we're up
three pawns as well as a queen for a
rook and a piece so we're up the
equivalent of basically like a queen
against a rook
this is easy stuff
just don't blunder your queen
and don't get backranked
and by the way i'm not just joking here
when you're in a completely winning
position but let's say you're in small
time pressure
what is a good practice a good practice
is to identify potential sources of
danger
so that doesn't mean you need to rush
and make luft immediately just tell
yourself okay i need to be a little bit
careful about the background
or
or make some luft if you have the chance
to do so
um
you know so when you or you might tell
yourself well i need to be careful about
the way my pieces are positioned so here
for example
the move bishop a4 would be a big
mistake believe it or not
and it is precisely again because of the
vulnerability of the queen the queen's
inability to be a reliable defender of
other pieces who can tell me why
after bishop a4 amazingly
black has the move rook to d8 the queen
must move now white is winning there too
and i'll show you guys how after the
game how do you do damage control in
such situations but
that's
uh unnecessary so what should we do here
how should white untangle the pieces
and the move here is a little bit
paradoxical
why are the pieces tangled up in the
first place it's because this queen is
on d5 stumbling and bumbling
um and getting in the way of the rest of
the pieces what we should do is just
drop the queen at f3 and in the event
that he plays rook ca we can either play
bishop d5 that's the tactical move or we
can simply oh no let's not preamp that
or we can play pawn d5 defending the
bishop
so that's the concept of the queen as
the supporting actress which
i've sort of peddled that article i
wrote on for chess.com a couple of years
ago yasser sarawan that's his phrase the
queen is the supporting actress
um
because from the shadows from a spot
where it's safe it does often times a
lot more productive work
and that should be
pretty intuitively clear once you pause
to think about it once you actually see
what could happen when the queen is
right in the thick of things is that to
say the queen should never be in the
thick of things obviously not
now between d5 and bishop d5 which move
is more accurate who can tell me
and what what is the purpose like
doesn't bishop d5 just hang a piece
thank you so much i appreciate it
it attacks f7 so you're going to take
with the queen
creating simultaneously a battery that
permits you to take on c4 when the queen
defends the bishop
so in that particular instance the queen
is a great defender
okay now um
don't do something fancy like queen f7
that's just asking for trouble
what's the simplest move here
the simplest thing to do here is to
understand what the drawback of bishop
d6 is the drawback of bishop d6
is that it lets it releases the f6
square we don't even need to trade the
rooks we can go queen f6 straight away
we can go queen f6 straight away
that's a fancy move
because if he takes the rook again we
take on f7 and then we deliver checkmate
on f6
for you guys i would propose taking on
c7 just to release the tension if you're
in time pressure don't
you know don't deliberately keep the
tension to show how cool you are it's
just i'm doing that here to showcase
what i think is the most accurate
winning path
knight d7
we can take anything we want
i think the simplest believe it or not
is oh no we have a more accurate move
who can tell me what the absolute most
accurate move is here what is the most
accurate move it's not queen takes f7
just the move that allows you to win the
most amount of pieces here it's bishop
takes f7 bishop f7
forcing the king to f8 now we gotta be
careful because
moving the moving the bishop away
uh opens up the queen to an attack so
instead we should play what should play
queen takes
all right
yeah don't worry i won't lose on time
okay
that's just for show
okay yeah i have to turn on the jets in
the end
okay so knight f6 let's get back to the
analysis
let's see if we can get one more game in
now
no i'm not trying to i mean
please understand that this is like not
this is not as hard as it looks
for those of you who have not seen i
mean i'm
i'm a pretty good bullet player so you
know i'm i'm used to this to converting
these positions with three four seconds
on the clock it's just a matter of
knowing the patterns it's not
it's honestly not nothing to write home
about if you have a million of these
mates you know what to do
okay
so bishop b5 check
knight b to d7
now
bishop d7 i believe is the more popular
move
and the idea here is to drop the bishop
back to e2
after knight takes d5 d4 look at how
awkward this bishop is it's it's like in
the way of everything so most of the
time black ends up making another move
with the bishop bishop f5 and white gets
a slight edge i mean
black's position is tremendously solid
so if you want a solid reputable line
this is
something to consider
um in addition there's sort of like a
positional trap here a lot of people
play c4 in this position
who can tell me why c4
is less good than it looks what is black
cabin response that's kind of annoying
easy question
so it's not like back to f6
it's it's not bishop before check
because
this doesn't do all that much you can
just block with the bishop
well knight have four blunders the
knight
and you know because here your bishop is
gonna hang you have to take and white's
gonna take with the queen white's in
great shape it's knight before it's not
bishop before it's knight before
why is this all of a sudden so good
because it's hard to defend against
knight c2
it's very hard to defend again in fact
white has only one serious defense to
knight c2 white must play knight a3
and look at how bad this knight is this
knight cannot re-enter the game
no tragedy has happened
nothing terrible has occurred but white
has all these developmental problems
here given that this knight is really
bad this knight is really good black is
super active he can strike in the center
with c5 this is annoying
so the way that i like to play this with
white
is to play the move
um sorry let me come back to this
position to play the move a3 first
prophylaxis covering the square
and then
bishop b7 c4 at f6 knight c3 with a
slight edge for white
but you can analyze this and perhaps
come close to equality or black
why is white slightly better because
white's got a little bit more central
control slightly more active development
stuff like that all right
um
anyways he goes knight b to d7 i see
three oh yeah and i was going to show
why c4 is not as good as it looks so
after c4 c6
if you end up taking
look at this position just sort of
carefully black's got a leading
development and and this hole on d4 is
horrific and in addition this bishop on
f1 can't really develop to an active
square so this is excellent position for
black if you end up going c4 you should
instead go d4 and transpose into the
panop attack of the karo khan which
frequently arises via the move order via
the karu khan move order c4 knight f6
knight c3
so this is just a transposition to the
pawn of where black is considered to be
totally fine according to theory but
it's an interesting line
all right knight b to d7
knight c3 a6 bishop b2
so again refraining from bishop a4 to b5
he goes knight b6 we go d4
and here he takes of the queen which is
interesting
but i thought knight takes d5 is more
solid then we would have gone knight f3
again similar type of position
but here and this is a great example of
not
you know of looking concretely this is
what you have to do when you hit like 18
1900. remember how i said c4 was bad in
the other position
but you cannot assume that c4 is bad in
this position and automatically play a3
because you're gonna waste time
c4 is good in this position why because
the situation is different the night
before
um there used to be
um
there used to be a
a pawn on e6 and so the knight was
protected now there's queen a4 check
which wins the game knight c65
uh b5 c takes b5 so
this is a great example of
thinking concretely even if you think
you know the idea
bishop f3
okay so queen b5 is what he played this
is risky but interesting and i think my
opponent started going wrong here
i think this was inaccurate
now why is this inaccurate because it
allows the bishop to remain on f3
using what i just said who can tell me
what a more accurate development move
would have been
bishop g4 is cooler that's right because
this invites a bishop trade that white
cannot refuse
why is the bishop trade good for black
because the bishop is clearly white's
strongest piece
takes takes and because of the
relatively tame nature of the position
black can afford to spend some time like
getting the knight to g4 maybe bringing
him back i think some people might be
uncomfortable it's like why are we
making a bunch of moves with the same
beast because
the reality of the position is that
white doesn't have the horsepower or the
firepower to really punish black for
this
the simple e6 i don't like because it
keeps the bishop very confined
i don't like e6 it's not terrible but it
it keeps the bishop very confined behind
the pawn chain although you might have
this idea of going bishop d7 to c6
so it's fine
bishop f5 castles and here comes the
sirius
e6 he just didn't feel the danger at
this point the danger is connected with
the fact that this b7 pawn is incredibly
vulnerable
castling long would have been i think
the best move
and a4 is now
not as effective because the king
has been delegated the assignment of
defending b7 so the queen can move
wherever it wants like queen c4
um maybe we would have still played a4
just to test where the queen wants to go
but even queen b6 as he played in the
game is is better here
a5 queen back to b5
and if we mimic the same sequence it's
still kind of good for white to be
honest with you i mean you bring your
pieces to active squares at the end of
the day he can play queen b6 and the b7
pawn is not hanging
or is it
oh my goodness this is really cute
what can white do in this position
loose pieces drop off that bishop on
five is undefended amazingly
miranda thank you for the prime we can
play bishop b7 anyway king b7 and now
fork the bishop and the king with queen
f3
so
i suppose
queen b5 maybe this move is too loose
and in combination with bishop f5 you
can see how good this bishop is
so after a4 he has that i think by queen
d7
this is probably the safest then
thank you mason gifting to twit max what
would white's idea be here
um
several possible options we can play c3
queen b3 trying to pile up on this pawn
but black has the strike with e5 well i
can go like this
you can't take the pawn and pawn can
shove its way to e4 very complicated
position i don't want to spend too long
but uh e6 e6's
is not great
and then i think the last moment he had
before he was losing is this position he
just he continued not to sense the
danger
um and queen b5 sort of shows to me that
he thinks he's totally safe and if you
look at this position
generally you might
be under the same impression but the
story of the game is this pawn on b7 and
the secondary storyline is the fact that
the queen just isn't a good defender of
weaknesses
um
bishop e4
in that line doesn't help as far as i
could tell
because bishop before you have knight
takes c4
this square is defended twice
does that make sense thank you susie for
the four months
pebbsman does that make sense
so 94 94 queen queen e4 that doesn't
help black at all that trade doesn't
help thank you chess gum roo
we you got a rates by silva
i'll just uh thank in
for the five gifted i appreciate it
and chess queen alexandra and maria
appreciate it
um
okay so we were talking about this line
this is winning for white
thank you 32 fight i appreciate it now
he plays e6 we go a4
queen b6 a5
um
queen b5 is the is the crucial mistake
knight c3
queen b4 rook a4
uh if if you've got queen b7 when we
take immediately so queen b4 k4 queen d6
bishop b7
queen f3 well i don't know i can't
answer that question dropped booty
because i
i mean russian is technically my first
language
um
okay so queen f3
is the crucial move right we don't just
drop our bishop back
oh what's up chickabook do i want 50
subs
i do
i want nothing more than to get to
receive 50 subs at this very second
not again this guy is this guy is crazy
i'm just gonna i'm not even gonna play
like i'm just gonna say yes
and i know it's coming
what about 51 subs yeah exactly
oh my goodness we all know what's coming
right now all right but let's focus on
the game i'm not
or let's not focus on the game let's
focus on the 50 subs we just got gifted
oh my god dikaio on top of it what is
this
what just happened
oh my gosh dikaio just gifted 50 subs on
top of that
oh my goodness this is completely
unexpected
this is completely what's up oh my
oh my kyo you're ridiculous and chig
bunga you're ridiculous too
you're both absolutely ridiculous i did
nothing to deserve this today i really
appreciate it
oh my gosh
well you know what that means chick
bunga right you've met an equal
hey this is one chess game i don't mind
seeing play out
all right
sub battles in the purest sense of the
word ridiculous stuff thank you for the
100 bits
absolute progress well thank you guys
two sets of 50 subs
i have no words right now
but i guess we'll return to the game for
now you can just sense
um
the atmosphere is very charged in a good
way
but i really appreciate it both of you
what supports me more uh
well
technically don't know i get
all of it but
um there's obviously more hypeles i mean
i i don't like talking about this
because everything is
incredibly supportive and i
i'm deeply honored that people do this
thank you followers and g cook with a
five gifted
oh my goodness
um
so
whatever makes you comfortable is
deeply appreciated
i yeah so i mean
formally i get half of the price of a
sub
um
but uh you know again it's
it raises the hype level and everything
is equally appreciated
um oh my goodness we're almost at 5 000.
that's crazy but let's get back to the
game for now
um
a bit less than half yeah it depends on
how much it costs now it costs different
for different people i think like
differently sometimes on the phone think
about neumann 137 for the three months
um
so we go queen f3 here right defending
the bishop
and paving the way for bishop c6 thank
you chief
thank you guys i really appreciate it
and the rest of the game is very
straightforward um
the rest of the game is very
straightforward bishop f4 let's have
brandon and x mr schrupp with the two
months oh my goodness
this is crazy
um
now
i wanna just to make one point clear
which is that
after a move like bishop e7
i would advise against bishop f4 and
like i was talking about during the game
what's wrong with bishop f4 absolutely
nothing thank you chick [ __ ] thank you
for the subs
really appreciate it
um
and um
this is obviously completely winning
queen d8 bishop takes a6 you're up two
pawns
what not
queen's c6 check is also good but
how can we prepare bishop f4 so that
it's even stronger when it's played you
can play rook c4
this is a difficult move for some people
to play because it involves
with it involves withholding and and
resisting the incredibly tempting move
until it's more opportune moment is more
opportune castles bishop f4 now look how
much stronger this is if he goes back to
d8 what do we have in this position well
we have bishop takes c7 winning the
exchange he goes queen to d7 and we take
with the rook with completely crushing
position we're up two pawns this is
hanging clearly this is losing
so
i think the golden rule here is not to
play moves just because they create
threats number one even if the threat is
very strong always consider whether you
can make a preparatory move uh to render
the threat even stronger
you know there's the phrase the threat
is stronger in the execution that has
something to do with this but it's a
slightly different point i'm trying to
make
what about bishop g4 where
oh yeah that is a good move
um
we could throw in a check now
that's a great question though thank you
neo for the five and this forces the
king away um but you're right i missed
bishop g4
i'm i'm sort of trying to illustrate a
more general point here so i i agree
but even something like this looks very
good because the king is permanently
devoid deprived of castling rights and
this is this is very strong so just
something to chew on i i agree that
maybe specifically here um bishop f4 is
not worse than rook c4
all right so i didn't grow up in
i grew up in san francisco but
i mean
my first language
is sort of both english and russian i
spoke
with my family
russian so that's how
okay so um
what
what
oh my god
what
oh my god
yeah we're definitely over 5k
damn girl that's a hundred gifted from
altar i think this guy gifted 100 before
i have absolutely no words right now
yeah i have no words
a hundred gifted from al altered i'm not
sure how to pronounce your last name but
that is unfreaking believable
you're the absolute man
stop subbing let me talk about the game
and everybody's distracting me i can't
even talk about the game what a toxic
chat
insane thank you so much i really
appreciate it
mr swiss thank you for the prime
man it's not stopping either
um
no i i still have to go at
at 5 55 but i will be back
as i said after the lessons for more
oh my god thank you i this is ridiculous
all right so
if you guys just stop being rude and
subbing and let me uh talk about the
game i'd really appreciate it
so bishop f4 is now much better because
if he goes queen d7 he gets pinned
um bishop c6 yeah we'll get one more
game in knight d7
and because we don't have to analyze the
rest of this game
uh the last thing i want to point out
here is this move rookie one how did i
find it well i looked around the
position for
what i would call i knew with five
gifted stop it this is crazy
um and i i noticed the fact that his
king and the queen are on the same file
every time the king and the queen are on
the same file you must notice that you
have to consider whether that plays into
your strategy here it obviously does
rookie one and then knight d5 is a very
typical tactical idea
and there's nothing he can do he is
totally paralyzed you can basically
pre-move knight d5 even if he attacks
your queen and you play knight t5 you're
still going to be winning because knight
takes c7 is a smother main this is
beautiful
so
he correctly sacrificed his queen
but
why not d5 so d5 would be totally
winning um but d5 is a little bit less
effective than it looks let's make a
random move for black
d5
let's let's make another random move
how are you going to follow this up
right you can take on e6 but you're not
completely winning just now i feel like
you're still gonna have to go knight d5
which you could totally do this would be
winning
but um i think knight d5 is a little bit
more incisive if that makes sense it
creates an immediate threat against the
queen uh as well as against c7 with some
other mate
um
so
that's really the bottom line here but
of course d5 is completely winning you
could even play bishop g3 here and
preserve the bishop first nothing wrong
with that or take on c7 and then go
knight d5 everything is winning
don't overthink it here that's that's
important
now okay the rest is easy the one thing
that i missed which would have made the
win even easier
is i failed to spot that the rooks are
both undefended loose pieces drop off
there's a very pretty move queen e5
using the pin sacking the bishop for the
greater good so to speak queen takes h8
um and you win another exchange now
you're totally winning
so queen e5 is the move
um yeah so hawk juice that's a good
point i just want to make this point as
a summarizing this is completely winning
but if you had a slightly less
one-sided position
you sometimes could pay the price for a
move like d5 so the way you should think
of a move like d5 there's two things you
need to consider when you're pushing
upon to open up the position three
things to consider the first is can my
opponent push this pawn forward right e5
now in this case of course the answer is
no
the second thing you need to consider
and this is what people i think fail to
take into account what if my opponent
ignores what i'm doing what if my
opponent does nothing or proceeds with
his plan
are you going to be able then
to follow up on your attempt to open up
the position and i think sometimes
people have this assumption that simply
the act of pushing down upon is going to
get the position to explode but that's
not quite true sometimes
you have to do additional work on top of
it
all right
[Music]